so can you yeah okay
it's weird
um so yeah welcome welcome everyone uh
today I will talk about ml Ops in
practice
and yeah without further Ado let's dive
into the agenda
so let me start with an introduction
where I'll introduce myself the company
and what we do in my team
and then I will explain how we de-risk
the migration from the batch to the
real-time inference by breaking it down
in multiple steps where each of them
added some values and how we and help us
learn basically on the way
then the second part I will explain the
challenges that Rose from this new
architecture and the key design decision
that we took to overcome them and
finally I will conclude and open for
questions
so
yeah I'm Theo I'm a data science manager
at get your guide and I will give you a
small snapshot of what we are doing at
ghetto guide for context so I'll get
your guide
um
but get to guide is a Marketplace for
travel experiences where we connect
customers with activity suppliers
worldwide and so you can book on our
website or on the app experiences
basically or activities
uh more precisely on my team in my team
who are responsible for ranking these
activities
and that you can see on the website or
the app and we have different type of
pages with different designs so which
come up with different flavor of ranking
so it's a critical component of our
website and
the major data product that we have in
our company
so with that as you can imagine trying
to send change such a system is a
sensitive topic for many people
and let's dive into this migration and
how we handle it and I explain first I
will explain where we started from and
where we wanted to go
so the first thing
um at the start or around two years ago
my team was responsible for the scoring
of every activities in our inventory by
doing some kind of daily daily batch uh
job and then we just pushed this car and
another team was responsible for ranking
the activity using this car that we
provided so it's a pretty simple to
maintain and well a simple interface
with the rest of the company but every
time you want to do any kind of testing
for a new scoring logic then we had to
we relied on another team and it was
very hard or nearly impossible to do any
kind of segmentation personalization
with this approach
so where we wanted to go was having our
own service that was responsible for the
ranking of the activity in real time
with their then the nice thing with that
is that we control the language logic so
we can use it for any kind of scoring or
we can have any form a formula or even
more even better model
but that's a new service that need to be
maintained by us
um so what our vision basically is was
to have this uh an ml model doing live
inference inside this ranking service
but that's not what we started to build
actually we wanted to de-risk this
Migration by breaking it down into
multiple steps and I will go through the
steps now with you so the first thing
that we did is to migrate the ranking to
the to to the service so basically what
we just did is just having the service
that was doing this lookup to the score
and then ordering based on this score
then with that we were able to prove the
visibility of having such service
and we could increase the speed of
launching a new experiment as we were
not relying on another team and also it
helped the team to learn the technical
challenges of operating in such a such a
service
then on the second step we started
segmenting our ranking depending on some
user signal like for example the
platform they are using or the language
so we were able to generate different
scores for every type of customers and
we were able to get a significant
Improvement of our ranking that help us
prove to our stakeholders that and
reinforce our hypothesis that the
ranking need to be contextualized and
personalized and we were going the right
direction basically
than what we did next step was to train
a model now to inside
to rank the activities inside the model
so we will use actually the segments
course that we that we generated in the
previous step and now we could train our
model to optimally combine these
segments based on some past data here
the the nice thing it was able to we
were able to stabilize the model in
production with this new framework of
having a Model A ranker more special
specifically
and also we learned a lot about how to
operate this machine learning model in a
real-time fashion and also how to
generate the data to train it
and finally we will we we went into
improving the model so what we added
start adding is adding more more
relevant feature from the user and from
the activity like the price or review
this kind of things and we fine-tune the
model
um and here we also were able to prove
significantly Improvement you know
ranking uh through a B test
and also we helped us to learn how we
can improve our offline evaluation
basically to select which model we want
to learn we want to test in production
for further iteration
okay so that's how we had this step by
step
um but as you can imagine operating such
a service has its own
um
onset of challenges and what I want to
go into in the second part is the key
design decision that we made to overcome
them
okay
so first thing let's start let's go into
the requirements that we have so first
the apps and the website need the
ranking to be able to show the the
relevant activities so that means that
we have a service that need to be
available 24 7 basically
then second thing is no one likes slow
website so that means that for us we had
pretty strict latency constraints under
100 milliseconds to to do the the
prediction
and finally there was a constant stream
of change coming from our mlops engineer
and also a data scientist and that's the
make like
we want to make it work so that's people
like these two type of experts uh in our
team was able to make change in parallel
without blocking each other and having
every time requesting a review view from
the other side for every little change
that we're doing
um so yeah
in in practice I think like that sounds
a pretty nice thing a pretty nice
receipt for incidents or big problems
you have a complex service with strict
operational constraints and where you
want to change constantly by different
type of people that have different array
of expertise
but actually we we manage our to keep
our system up and without any incidents
we're able to launch experiment in days
compared to months as we had with the
previous setup where we were relying on
other teams
and so for that I I I put like three
um three pillars that I I think help us
the most uh to to to be able to
to achieve that the first one is to have
an explicit ownership so uh among the
experts that we have in our team second
one we use extensively or end-to-end
test and where we use real data instead
of dummy data in particular and finally
we automated all the workflow to uh test
train deploy as part of a CI
and now let's dive into each of them
okay the first one
we used ml flow to be able to clarify
the interface between our data
scientists and the mlops engineers
and for the one that do not know ml ml
flow is an open source library that is
able that the uh that help manage the
model life cycle and to end
and with ML flow basically for us what
he what it helped was to clarify this
interface and then the data scientists
can focus on generating the feature and
the data that we that are needed then
Define the pre and prosprocessing as
part of a psychic Rod pipeline so that
everything is packaged together in one
one big model for on the ml float on IMO
flow sense and finally
train and store the model in Mr flow and
then we have the mlops engineer that are
responsible for loading this model from
the storage so from ml flow storage then
provide the feature for the inference
and ensure the the service stay healthy
during the during all the time basically
great
um that's the first pillar the second
one is about validating our machine
learning Pipeline and what we struggle
for quite some time about about that and
what we come up to is the my pipeline is
mainly about the interaction between our
codes and the data
and also the ml data sets are very
unstable because
you are constantly adding new data
sources or new features as you evolve
and so every few weeks basically you are
changing something in there
and finally if you are using any kind of
dummy data which we
we try to to stop using them because
it's cumbersome to create this dummy
data it's also hard to maintain uh these
hard-coded values or it's this kind of
data set generation to have this dummy
data data set and
finally there is a risk that it drifts
from True production data it happened
that you expect to have a timestamp and
actually you get the daytime or this
kind of thing that
you suddenly the data that you will have
in production is different so your your
test looks fine but actually when you go
to production boom it breaks suddenly
uh so we came to the conclusion that we
needed to use production data for
testing uh but
uh we needed to be able to sample it to
to be able to run it in a reasonable
amount of time
okay and so for that we needed some more
some more tooling and we developed an
open source data flow so it's a tool
that help us to sample and run
end-to-end tests
as part of a CI
um yeah you can check it out on Pipi and
here on this diagram I will have briefly
explain kind of the philosophy behind
the library so basically with this
Library you you can specify the data
sources that you that you that you want
to sample in some you know config and
then you can use data flow object to
read the data and
when you run your code basically you can
have you have some settings that specify
the which data you want to use so if the
data flow is enabled then the code will
run fast wait maybe sorry
uh let me add so is enable then the code
will run fast because you will use a
data source that are sampled but if you
if it's disabled which it is by default
then you will run the full data sources
basically and your model will will run
on everything and uh
finally you can also use this data flow
to download the data so that you are
also able to develop locally on a small
subset of real data
um the the thing is running this code on
this sample data make them like if you
run any test then it makes them done
deterministic you cannot expect 1.43 or
onto your output of your model or
something like that so here we also
needed to tweak a bit of our approach
around our assertion for testing and
what we came up with is adding some kind
of thing that we we call health check so
in other words some kind of expectation
that we have for our data sets and our
model
so as an example uh we expect that the
data sets have a certain share of booked
activity the share of booked activity to
be in a certain range or for example for
the model that accuracy to be above a
certain threshold
and so we can build all this kind of
help strike to validate that the data
and the model is kind of reasonable
before we deploy them the the thing that
we want to divide is that we forgot a
minus somewhere and basically we rank
them on the other things and we put the
worth activity on top uh that was kind
of the the big fear that we had
um so
sorry oh yeah uh then we we can run this
health check as part of the CI based on
some sample data
and of course then we used it with
combination with sampling with data doc
but also this health check can also be
run as part of the production Pipeline
on the full data set uh and on the
production model
and also if you remember the definition
the example I say I gave about the
health deck they are based on some kind
of metrics like accuracy or share of
booking you know data set and so we can
also send like compute this metrics and
send them to data dog or any other
dashboard so that we have a dashboard of
can get a overview of our service and
also we can also send alerts
about if some metrics have some
dangerous Trends basically
okay so to be more visual how it looks
like about this uh data health check in
end-to-end test so we first have the we
sample our production data with the data
flow then we can generate the data sets
we can validate the sample data sets
with this health check then we can train
on bottle with this validated sample
data set and validate the sample data
the sample model in the same altogether
great
and that's I mean you see with these
buildings above actually that you see we
can reuse them and we can reduce them
for also reproduction data set and the
production model and that brings us to
our last point the automation that we
introduce in our workflow
and so for that what we ended up doing
is that we automated every step in our
testing and deployment process in oci so
that means that every time we have a
change then we run the unit test like
normal then we run this end-to-end test
with data where we'll have this all the
step running
where we'll sample the data run the
run the render health check train a
model on Sample data around the health
check again and at the end what we can
do is put this model in push this model
into ml flow then this step basically
then we can have some integration tests
where we can load this model and see if
we're able to build a service with that
and run some integration tests with the
rest of the of the service
once it's done if and it looks fine then
we can trigger start on the deployment
that means that we can train a model now
here again we can launch a training job
one more time but this time we're using
production data all the data sets and
also as it's the building blocks can be
reused and we say okay we can also reuse
this building blocks to validate after
that
um model with production data is saying
and finally we again push it to ml flow
and then we can start our deployment
process
great
um
yeah so now we can deploy the new
services so what happened here is we
will load the model wrap it into a
Docker image
and then we can send it to our
orchestration deployment registration
tool Argo
and this uh allow us to have a we also
put some additional safety here around
Canary deployment
um oh sorry
because it makes sure that our model is
not breaking
um with rural requests and also we still
that we are still respecting our latency
constraint and so if a model that we
launched suddenly is too slow then we
will start breaking the request and the
canary step will fade basically and also
knighting on the other side and
the also finally the packaging of our
model into into this Docker image make
it easy to roll back as we have a Docker
image and which is uh very similar to
any other services that we have at get
your guide
and finally we also have an airflow Dag
uh that uh is triggered every day so
that we generate a new uh data set for
the for the new day basically and here
again we can train some uh we can also
verify that this new terrainly uh this
new data set is correct and with using
the Sam health check and actually we
always build this health check for the
CI and we thought like well you never
know we can also do it in production but
ah if it buys the CI it should not work
but actually we had an incident recently
that on a pipeline view above and thanks
to this health track failing we avoid uh
cascading to our model and starting
having a rubbish data set that will have
trained a rubbish model to go to
production
um so yeah that's basically how we do so
we make sure that we automate everything
and every time we have a new change
basically we will automatically run all
these steps which means that we'll test
end-to-end that the data data set is
still correct that we can train a model
that we can integrate the model and if
it passed and we'll train a new model
and deploy it with the and after
verifying it's uh able to handle the our
production traffic
and that's make sure that we remove by
automating everything we remove a room
for manual error we simplify our
deployment process
and that increase the speed of
development for everyone
so with that let's conclude
um yeah today I showed how we improved
our ranking and the risk of migration
I'm way too fast sorry I was uh sorry
I'm uh
I will try to slow down
too late
um so yeah I show how we improve our
ranking and there is the Migration by
moving step by step so I explained that
the three design decision that we
that that we take that help us
go to the state that we are so we have a
explicit or clear ownership between with
the ml flow as the interface between our
data scientists and now I'm a Labs
engineer we use production data for
testing and with health check and
finally we automated our full deployment
with the CI including some data set
generation and the model serving
and yeah of course our journey was
actually full of surprise
um we struggled for multiple iteration
for example to improve the the ranking
by segmentation and uh yeah the learning
curve also for our ranker model was not
as smooth as expected and we I think
also uh we could have made the
integration uh some integration tests
earlier in the process as we ended up
but uh yeah at the end we have a pretty
robust uh process and service
and yeah finally I think this work was
actually work from not for me only but
from the whole team and uh yeah it's for
many months and even yeah more than one
year uh so yeah Special science thanks
to some people especially Jean Xing Ting
Olivia Max and nehail that's also helped
me on this uh
that's it
thank you
[Applause]
all right Peter thank you for your talk
you were very fast but that gives us
fortunately time for some interesting
questions
first one how are you sampling the data
are there additional steps to check that
your data is representative
uh yes
um so
we also struggle a list we we came up
with the the best idea was actually you
are responsible to Define as part of the
data source how you want to sample the
data and so for us what made the most of
sense was actually to uh to look at some
specific key that we use so most of the
join that we're doing are made on some
visitor idea which represents for every
browser basically you have a kind of
visitor idea assigned to in your cookie
and that's what we use along the chain
to to create the data set and so for us
what made sense is to actually join on
have some kind of pattern on this
visitor ID to say oh you have to start
with AAA as a on this on this unique key
to be able to to to be in this sample
data so I may allow us to sample and we
expect this this to be a representative
sample what we wanted to avoid is we say
oh we just sample the first 10 000 but
then when we start joining the data set
together then of course it's unlikely
that a sample data set from this and
this will when I join them and if we
just take a random sample it's unlikely
that we'll be able to join them together
if they are just randomly sampled so
that's the the main thing that we had to
take care of yeah that makes sense
definitely
um next question is how did you ensure
data privacy when using real data for
model testing
um still everything is in the in our
Cloud actually so except when we load
the data but that's also on some uh some
personal laptop basically that oh sorry
not personal laptop but the the laptop
of the of the company first we we have
no uh sensitive information in our model
as a ranking uh we don't we don't we are
not able to extract things but uh sorry
integration But to answer the the
question is
it's part of the CI so if you have their
model there
um
it's
we just automated this process of doing
this sampling but if you you have access
to data and if you don't have access
then you have access to nothing or if
you have access to everything then
you'll also have access to a sample
subset of it that you can also train to
create a sub sample model basically does
that make sense or
audience does it make sense okay thank
you
next questions
um first of all I've won um one year
that says could you show what the data
scientist and ml engineer
responsibilities
uh could you show that on the diagram of
workflow or automation I think there was
a slide this and this one I suspect uh
so
is it from the audience
whoever wanted to see can look at it now
while we are continuing with the other
questions uh I will share the the slides
also in the channel afterwards so you
can see them but was it a question about
what who is responsible for which Step
basically
also or yes I guess that was the
question okay
um so basically then the unit test is a
shared responsibility depending on the
area of the code that it is then this
end-to-end tests are definitely on the
data science to Define what other data
and unit tests that you want to want to
do for the data set generation and the
model training that's part of the data
set of the data scientist then pushing
to ml flow then loading this model and
doing this integration test as is on the
ML on the sorry it's on the ml apps
engineer then training this is then on
the data scientist pushing it the data
scientists and deploying and these steps
is then on the mlops engineer and yeah
building this data set is also part of
the data scientist
all right very nice next questions what
might you switch from Benton Bento ml
sorry you reply you apparently
apparently presented it at a conference
last year to the southern core I guess
you have a fan here wow
for the sake of uh brevity because I
didn't think it was
important for this talk but we are still
using band 2ml and it's part of our
deployment actually when when we load
the model we load the Mr flow model and
the wrapper that we use to create from a
model Transformer model to a web service
is Bend to ml I I didn't want to I was
not a key part of this talk so that's
why I remove it and I'm sorry if I
offended some people
all right next one do you have
developmental production accounts in
your Cloud environment for proper
testing and development if so how do you
move the data and models around
uh yes at this time like we we have data
breaks so where we have a lot of access
uh so basically we are able to
to move the data around
um but we we mainly the I think the the
thing is if we're not familiar with
database basically they provide a kind
of UI that helps you that data
uh data platform uh service that help
you with uh having some
a nice way to to have analysis and do
machine learning also and then that's
what we can use to easily create a
cluster and be able to start moving the
data around and things like that so uh
yeah
yeah I think I answered all of the
question is so we don't have directly
access to AWS to be able to spin up AC
to instance or things like that but
actually through the Fabrics we can
create cluster and be able to move
things around
oh
all right makes sense next questions
with respect to the explicit ownership
we have problems to find people for the
ml Ops part is there a typical
background where your envelopes
Engineers come from
[Laughter]
um
yes we struggle uh also
we
no I don't have like a magic answer I
think for other magic answer I would uh
I will keep it for myself to be honest
but I can already tell you like it's
hard to find people with right skills on
these ml Ops engineer side
yeah all right
how did you decide on your mlops tooling
so airflow Argo data bricks ml flow have
you encountered problems that will make
you switch in the future
um
so what's so actually I I
John and I
um worked a lot uh quite a bit on this
ml platform and we decided a lot of this
what other tool that we're using uh
actually what's the thing that we end up
doing is like we wanted to use as much
as possible what was already used by the
company already and that means that's
our deployment Pipeline with Argo is
basically all before what we had was
Pinnacle but basically we just decided
to keep with them so that we have one
deployment tool that is the same than
the rest of the company for any other
services
some some studying something are not
possible one one example this is ml flow
like there is no way your your classical
company has a things to be able to store
models and so here we introduced the
tool that we're making the most sense
and mlflow is really well integrated
with data breaks so we made the list of
prone crones and decided to do that so
that's how we went to do this and most
of them actually have been things that
we start reusing and we're just
combining them with things that we
um we just reuse the thing that is in
the company and just tweak them up
really push them to limits like one
example is our CI that is taking a bit
longer than most of the CI of the other
services but still adjust the CI like
any other services
all right very nice
is airflow only used for building the
daily data set what is the advantage
over using something simpler for these
for example Chrome job
uh yes it's please use airflow because
uh
Cron job really get messy and it it will
be already very messy for us to use
something as an airflow because to be
able to uh to have our daily data daily
data ready we also rely on some previous
pipeline that are scheduled on airflow
to be able to clean the data of the
previous day and put them into the right
into the right formats and only when
it's done then we can trigger our data
set training so here again we didn't
want to re reinvent the wheel we already
use airflow which was used by all
everything on our core data engineering
and we just added those things on top of
it otherwise yeah I have no idea how
much work were yeah I will still be
working on this
okay even with real data testing it
should be the same each time thus the
data drift problem still applies if so
or not
uh so I think I have two two things
first thing is uh if you use real data
it should still be the same yes but uh
the thing is the data basically we use
the data of the last week and the data
of the last week is changing depending
on the day you run the pipeline so we
our data is changing at the uh every
time you run the CI depending on the day
you will have different data and do we
still have data drift yes uh we are
looking into that so we recently
introduced a new tool to look into ml
monitoring and this data drift in
particular but the the best thing you
can do and we know we we do it by
default it's actually you retrain your
model regularly which is for us every
day and that makes sure this data Rift
can cannot go too fast but we are also
looking into some ml monitoring tool but
yeah a small handle might be highlight
this time
okay how do you assemble data from
different sources which have to be
joined later yeah I think I already
answered is for us the thing that they
are trying on the visitor ID and so we
have some specific condition on this
visitor ID which is just like some Alpha
numerical string and we say we are on
Alpha things then uh we just look at the
one for that start with AAA which make
it like basically
all the others we ignore and just it's
just a random sample and we make sure
that we can get them through their list
of events
I can't believe we made it through all
the questions this is the last one how
do your models interact with the front
and back-end apps
um
yeah good question uh I will need
another talk to talk about that I think
uh I mean at the end we just have an
endpoint and then we basically provide
this endpoint to any services that want
to need to rank activities so basically
they need to send us a list of
activities and send it back but there
are many steps in the process of like
getting the from the activity to getting
the picture the title for the right
language uh the price Etc so there are
many steps that happen afterwards but
yeah
uh not I not the most uh the best person
to explain everything around that
all right thank you very much give it up
for theater
[Applause]